do this ladies and gentlemen
we are live once again
let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to
your favorite podcast
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to ripping
with Griffin the podcast that brings it
to you live and full effect today Last
of Us review NFL final four the M Ms
that's weird it's Carol baskin's husband
still alive and a few more things but
welcome
[Music]
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
yeah
oh I was feeling my woo-woos today
what's up y'all welcome back to Roofing
with Griffin oh I forgot to put my title
card on but whatever
had a long day today so it is what it is
we're from Griffin there it is
airgriffin.com make sure you check me
out there I gotta fix my website
something's going on funky with my
website when it's on the phone you gotta
anyways I'm gonna change that I'm gonna
figure that out anyways make sure you
subscribe share
um you know do all that good stuff love
that follow me on Twitch which I'll be
on Twitch right after Eric Griffin
gaming I got a bunch of videos that I
put up there so check me out there and
uh you can be uh patreon subscriber a
YouTube member
a twitch subscriber any of those things
that you'd like to do to uh support the
show will be much
appreciate it y'all
um and before we even start new sponsor
of the show today's show is sponsored by
kickoff
kick off
you know helps you with your credit
score so what are you waiting for apply
right now in minutes at kickoff.com to
start your building Better Credit that's
kickoff
kikoff.com to build your credit score
without Lyft start today at kickoff.com
all right what's up everybody
um I gotta remember don't forget to
remind me I gotta do my do that again
later what's up what is up boom the
wallet there's the wallet y'all I got
this see how beautiful this wallet is
Rachel got me this wallet and it is just
fabulous you know what I mean I got my
lotto tickets I gotta check and see if I
didn't win I could have possibly won
something to take that stuff out of
there but anyways lost my wallet I don't
know what y'all have in your wallet but
I try to minimize you know what I have
in my wallet you know it's like I have
like insurance information
you know just insurance card and I only
have like a couple of credit cards I
don't really I actually have too many
credit cards in here right now that [__]
you know I just don't like carrying
stuff because of the idea that you might
lose your wallet you know what I'm
saying I got cash in here you know what
I mean it's like damn you know when you
feel like you lost your wallet it's like
it's such a sucky thing but yeah but
here's the wallet y'all from last week's
episode and The Saga that I I put on
Instagram you know but again thanks for
being here the the chat is live in full
effect right now so I appreciate you
guys
you know so thanks thank you for being
here uh you know you guys and everybody
listens to me on the audio platforms I
appreciate you help me spread the word
man we got to keep spreading the word uh
I always say about the podcast this is
just my random thoughts and ideas
sometimes it's funny sometimes it's not
but it's always authentically me that's
for the new people the old people that
come all the time you already know what
it is and we're here uh please send me
like I'd you know if you guys have
thoughts and ideas you know send it to
me at my email at Eric ericgriffin.com
you know send me that stuff there so we
could uh you know I'll read your emails
I'll read your comments and that kind of
stuff if it's uh you know appropriate
you know you know it's like there's
always going to be a lot of trolls but
you know it is what it is I don't really
care you know trolls are going to be
trolls so it's like that's just all part
of being online so I appreciate
and you know I just appreciate
everything about you know the my my
audience you guys are just very
supportive and I appreciate that
um
you know so like like for instance right
now a guy sent me a message last episode
just to read a comment the truth thank
you the truth he said I'm not want to
comment on podcast but I just wanted to
let you know
um I just wanted to let you know that
ever since you decided to mix it up and
be more about an everything discussion
show I'm loving it more
uh so I love that thank you for that uh
somebody else wrote Apollo 209 Rachel
finds a wallet within five seconds of
trying it's the universe way of telling
you she's gonna be a good she's going to
be a mom soon
fingers crossed right we are trying I'm
working on it uh so yeah lots of uh good
comments on here I really appreciate
that
um Justin Schwartz Sports Recaps are
always on point should be an ESPN
regular you know let's put that out
there in the universe that'd be great
Steve Beck the intro just made my day
thank you Eric thank you Steve for that
comment
um
here's uh April Joy someone should tell
Griffin he needs to interact with his
fans to build a fan base
you know what I mean I'm on my twitch
and all the stuff all the time if you
were if you're a twitch follow me on
Twitch you know I interact a lot but how
about that April interacting with your
ass right now
uh anyways so those are just some of the
comments thanks for commenting and uh
being here regularly guys appreciate you
uh yes this is live lost thanks for uh
coming in on the chat there so what's up
guys uh yeah so I've got my wallet
nothing really to report this week
Janine with more Super chats oh man you
know what I mean I appreciate
man I I don't even know what to say when
you guys when you guys do the super
chats I really appreciate that I love
the support you know keeps me doing it
uh keeps me out here in these streets so
I appreciate that you know and because
we got a super chat from Janine once
again a night 1999 Super Chat girl what
[Music]
from Jimmy
so we rewind
okay that's all you get
sometimes we go to the singer Mike for
no reason that's what we do on riffing
with Griffin so
um
what is happening a lot going on uh you
know a lot going on uh for people that
don't like sports now well I don't
should I go right to the sports you know
what I mean how you guys no let's not go
right to the sports you know let's go to
the thing that the thing that's on the
um uh my my uh my my uh what is it uh
the uh
the page thing the um
the the thumbnail today the thumbnail
today is this crazy story about Eminem's
man
like what is this you know I didn't know
about this
sir Ryan Vine I see you with the Super
Chat I'll hit you in a second
um yeah this whole thing with the m M's
like so I got you can't really see the
the whole picture but like you know they
changed the green Eminem like the
picture looks weird man so there it is
before the green m m had like high heels
sexy eyelashes sexy lips sort of you
know and then they changed it stubby
your legs no makeup it's like I don't
understand the controversy you know it
so they changed it so now they got my
Rudolph coming in they had all these
weird backstories they're trying to be
more inclusive I don't know if taking
away sexiness means you're being
inclusive like if you're taking away
every sexuality if you're taking away uh
you know attractiveness or whatever or
what we think is attractive and sexy and
what you know gets our blood boiling you
want to take all that stuff away how's
that being inclusive I don't think
that's the problem I don't even think
feminists like that if you're a feminist
it's like being sexy and being feminine
being like an even even sexuality in a
Man Too like being a handsome sexy guy
with your abs out and all that stuff is
that the problem or is it how we
treat people it's you know I don't know
it's it's a crazy nuanced thing man
because I feel like
as long as you use sex to sell things
people we will be objectified mostly
women because that's what we use mostly
women you know car shows boxing matches
cheerleaders anything we're using uh you
know even sexy waitresses you know we
ever go to a restaurant and a waitress
is extra sexy like you know what I don't
understand about that like what does
what does
um ass and titties have to do with food
and beverage you know what I mean like
what does that have to do with the
quality of food and beverage out of
place like if I blindfolded you and I
brought you a hamburger you wouldn't be
like this feels like a fat guy brought
it to me you know what I'm saying but
that's how we that's how it is so as
long as we use sex to sell things the
object of that is going to be
objectified so I don't know what they're
trying to do I don't know what Eminem's
point was to be like all right well
let's you know let's maybe not have this
and who cares here's the thing I I you
hear about the Illuminati you know
there's this like thing if I don't know
if you believe in the Illuminati I don't
know is there a cabal of super rich
people who control everything Maybe
but it seems to me the real Illuminati
is this
Twitter
internet
very small percentage of society that
seems to be controlling the narrative
for our entertainment and news
like that seems to be the real
Illuminati the real Illuminati is
whoever these people were like oh well
Twitter was going crazy because of
whatever the issue is and I'm being 100
with you I don't know one person who
gives a
I won't even say the word I don't know
one person that cares about this I don't
know that person who is that person do
you know a person that worries about
this tell me if you know a person and
I'm being 100 with you be in the
comments please tell me oh yeah it's my
aunt uh my sister oh I care about it uh
who cares about the M Ms like this
why
I don't know who these people are that
are on Twitter that we care about their
opinion so much that is making
corporations and companies you know uh
you know change how they do business and
it doesn't seem to work who's it for who
are these people they're the real
Illuminati it's these keyboard Warriors
they seem to be making the biggest
difference
for certain companies Twitter don't even
have that kind of Engagement this is the
thing I don't understand they're showing
there's like some figures that it's not
even it's not even like 50 of the
population or even on Twitter or even
use it when you look at somebody's uh
profile that has like a lot of followers
and you look at their likes you're just
kind of like well are these followers
real or do people even it doesn't mean
that no one cares even Elon Musk has
over 100 million followers he never gets
100 million likes I've never seen one
post of his that has gotten a hundred
million likes so it either means these
people are fake or people just don't
care or they're just not on it like that
so who are these people
you know I just I don't get it I don't
get why they made such a thing Tucker
Carlson on [__] Fox he's over there
making a whole thing about it like you
know it's like just playing to his base
like you know they're doing it again the
Liberals are doing it again and I just
like I I don't get it
I don't get it Like That Eminem that
green Eminem right there like are you
trying to have sex with this Eminem is
that what you're trying to do are you
seeing this Eminem and you're like oh
yeah
oh that's what I like that round green
figure with those sexy lips and those
high heels oh wait that's how I like my
candy
I like my candy but I wanna I wanna go
down on that cake like what are you
talking about like who cares right I'm
talking about it because it's so silly I
just find it silly I just really find a
city silly and then I was looking at
like trying to find the stories like
what like break down this for me and I
don't I can't get one article that
explains why this is such a big deal
like Eminem put out a statement Eminem's
put out a statement a company there you
know whatever that company's name is and
they're like they wanted a more Dynamic
Progressive world that we're living in
so we wanted to change the M M's like
who cares this is like a group of fat
kids right that's what their little M
M's are they're they're always portrayed
as like dumb they're being eaten by
human beings like like what are we
talking about this isn't real okay like
just some freaking candy what are we
doing stop it you're coming across as
stupid like of all the things we go
worry about gun control or voting
but if you're worried about
sexiness of M Ms what
I don't know
I do not low-key care you piece of [__]
there's always some [__] in the chat
no man I just I care about
that
we live in a society that people care
about this that's what I'm concerned
about if that makes sense we can't live
in a society where people make this
an indictment on you know even this
company who's just selling candy they're
just selling candy like the real issue
should be about the sugar addiction that
we have in our society this should be
more about obesity it should be more
about you know what I mean like the
grams of sugar that are in a packet of M
M's not how they're marketing the M Ms
think about that wow
mind-blowing right
I'm not saying it to Green look the
green Eminem I mean look I mean you know
what I'm saying like when you see the
green banana what makes that green m m
sexy is it the boots is it the long legs
the High I mean I don't know is it the
eyes with the lashes and the lips these
are the kind of things we go oh that's I
mean I don't I what I'm saying is I've
never thought about it you know I've
never watched an M M commercial and been
like oh damn they they doing too much
they doing too much with that green
Eminem stop you trying to get it girl no
it's never what are you talking about
I'll eat all these M M's you know what
I'm saying they all getting it all these
M M's getting it the sexy one the chubby
one the dumb one the nerd on the end the
librarian brown one where's the
librarian wait how do I do this oh that
way that one right there the librarian
brown one gonna get it too what are we
talking about
you know they make like well look what
they did to the poor librarian one made
that with dumpy as hell why you don't
make that brown m m dumpy the brown one
so we're gonna make the brown one dumpy
you know what I mean like I just I don't
know all these M M's gonna get it okay
they're gonna be in some yogurt and
they're gonna get it nobody cares about
how sexy they are it's just it's just
what are we doing like if you're one of
those people out there in front of your
keyboard worried about this
you need to go get some M Ms or go get
laid
I think that
it's a lot of people not having Intimate
Relationships that are worried about
this kind of stuff
because once you get into a relationship
and you have to worry about that
person's feelings and thoughts and you
you you you
get some relationships in your life so
you can stop worrying about
how sexy or non-sexy a goddamn Eminem I
keep doing it wrong not keep doing wrong
again wait wait there it is that one
whatever
okay
I'm done with that
I'm done with these dumbass M M's man
all right
you know what we'll do right now let us
let us talk about our new sponsor kick
off y'all kick off I don't know if you
guys what your credit score is like and
you I didn't know until I got to an
adult I wish somebody had talked to me
about keeping your credit score at a
certain point a certain level how
important it is to pay your bills on
time how important it is to build a good
credit history you know if you're ready
to take the next step in your life
whether it's buying a new car or moving
into a different apartment or buying a
house the first step is having a healthy
credit score I can't stress at you
enough how important having a healthy
credit score is and so kick helps you
with that life isn't always easy but it
could be easier if you're looking to
boost your
boost your life you want kickoff helps
you to build your credit score so you
can be on your way to getting the things
you want most and not just getting the
things you want most but getting the
things you want most at a good rate I
mean it's crazy how they do this they
you you know how it's crazy how credit
works because if you have bad credit
then they're making you pay more with a
higher interest rate which don't make
sense to me because it means this
person's already showing I don't have
the money to do this so it's like you
have to when you have a great credit
score you're getting lower interest
rates and all that and I'm telling you
how I did it you know it's like you know
you pay off your credit cards all those
times you got to pay off your credit
cards you have to make sure you're not
using all of your credit at the same
time you know and so credit kickoff is
going to help you with all of that all
right you have even you can set up
autopay with this plans started just
five dollars a month and every and every
on-time payment you make kick offers
reported to the major credit bureau when
they see healthy habits you see a
healthier credit score so talk about so
so what are you waiting for apply right
now in minutes at kickoff.com to start
building Better Credit that's
k-i-k-o-f-f.com to build your credit
score get it up get it up start today at
kickoff
.com
all right y'all
let's get into
let's get into this football now right
we gotta get into this football
where is it where's my football thing
where is it oh here it is NFL
boom
I gotta turn this off and turn this on
oh wait a minute there we go boom yes
NFL playoffs everybody let's talk about
these NFL playoffs
all you Sports Heads This is I'm the e
in ESPN so this is the ESPN portion of
the show The Eric Sports whatever I
don't know what that would stand for but
anyways NFL playoffs how exciting so we
had the San Francisco
San Francisco playing
the Dallas Cowboys
um what a game
Dallas did everything they could
possibly do they held this high-powered
offense which was been scoring 33 points
a game they held him down to what was it
20 or something like that just below 30
you know Dallas's defense did what they
were supposed to do
it's a couple of the offensive pieces
showed up like CD lamb you know who
didn't show up Dak Prescott that
Prescott showed us who he is this is
seven years in the league now Dak as the
starter making an exorbitant amount of
money good for him get your money but
Dak Prescott he ain't the one man he
ain't the one
uh it's just his you know he's a really
great dude I love his commercials I love
hearing him talk he always says the
right thing but just because somebody's
a good person doesn't mean they're a
good football player or a great football
player he's just average he didn't even
have to be great in this game he didn't
have to be even good in this game he
just needed to not suck and he couldn't
do that the interceptions the bad
decisions just they needed Dak to be
like how he was last week but he played
against a really terrible team I picked
the 49ers to win this game I thought
they would win the game I thought they'd
win the game by more but shout out to
Dallas's defense Dallas's defense they
did their job so but now let's talk
about the 49ers
absolutely fabulous I personally believe
they're the they're probably almost the
best team okay the only thing the only
thing that stops them from me being the
very best team
from top to bottom I think they are the
best team like just talent wise offense
defense all the um intangibles that they
have it's just Brock Purdy still a
rookie man he's only every game he plays
is adding to his young resume of games
played so so can he get them to a Super
Bowl and win is there going to be a
moment that we're going to have to rely
on Brock Purdy to go down the field and
you know in six plays and score a
touchdown can he do that we'll see I
think he's got a great team around him
and they are oh my God they are pulling
him through and he's ju he's not losing
it for them you know what I mean he's
making he's not making terrible
decisions he's just like I'm gonna
protect this ball I'm not gonna let the
team down can that win a Super Bowl
we'll see but everything else on that
team is just
dact man stacked so I really uh enjoy
watching San Francisco 49ers okay so cut
to the other side now uh not the I mean
the other in the other in the same
bracket the Eagles the best team all
year Jalen Hurst got hurt then they they
lost a couple of games regarding them
into me jalenhurst proved that he is the
MVP because you can see what they did
without him but his team
they put the whoop on the Giants okay
they let the whole league know our guy
was hurt he's back he's ready he's a
hundred percent and we're The League is
on notice the rest of these teams are
like no no the Eagles are the truth they
look great we're getting the match up we
want Eagles 49ers the best offense best
defense best o-line second best o-line
best d-line they gonna go at each other
are these two quarterbacks I think Jalen
Hurst is a better quarterback than Brock
Purdy he runs better he's more physical
he's more talented but he may not have
the same equal amount of talent it at
position players that uh San Francisco
has so we'll see man we will see
the rut I mean both teams can stop the
rush both teams are got great dogs in
the secondary both teams have great
coaches and offensive schemes defensive
schemes this is the game we want in
terms of like football play in terms of
like if you're gonna you're watching
like a great defense and a great another
great defense and like who can overcome
that's gonna be the game of the week for
that
all right looking forward to it
uh it's you know this is this to me is
one of the most exciting playoffs we've
seen in a long time really can't wait to
watch the final four weekend and I'll be
in Vegas for the Super Bowl because I
love going to Vegas for the Super Bowl
all right and the other side Kansas City
they did their job against the Jags you
know kudos to the Jags and Doug Peterson
Doug Peterson is a great coach he has
got he's gonna make Trevor Lawrence a
star Trevor Lawrence is going to be one
we're going to be talking about him in
the same way we talk about all these
other great quarterbacks that team look
out for that team in a couple years
they're gonna they're gonna be good they
they played their heart out uh it's just
you know Patrick Mahomes man the Chiefs
are just that team
I don't think they're the best team but
Patrick Mahomes is just magical and he
did his thing so I'm looking forward to
that but the chief did their job now cut
to the other game and I called this I
called this game
I picked the Bengals to beat the bills
I don't think the bills scheme as how
they run their offense through Josh
Allen I don't think you can win like
that I don't think they're gonna be able
to win a Super Bowl relying so much on
their quarterback to he was the leading
rusher on their team to be to pass to be
super on third down every single time
they need a better running game they
need a better scheme so he doesn't have
to do so much because in big moments
against really great teams if they take
that away then what I think the Bengals
are the best team I think from top to
bottom the Bengals and 49ers they're the
best teams and Joe burrow is for Real
y'all Joe burrows for real that dude's
the truth okay like
forget about all this other stuff forget
about all these people you say oh this
person looks more talented this person
has a bigger arm this person's faster
stronger nah man Joe burrow got that
stuff he got that thing man he got it
and he's already beaten Patrick Mahomes
three times in a row now he's beating
Josh Allen he went to the Super Bowl
last year and you know what they going
to the Super Bowl this year I'm calling
it right now I don't think Kansas City
has enough if if Patrick Mahomes isn't
100 I think the Bengals are on a mission
and they go into the Super Bowl and
we're going to see a rematch of I think
it's going to be 49ers Bengals in the
Super Bowl I'm calling that it's going
to be a rematch and I think the Bengals
are gonna win it there boom that's my
prediction right now but I wouldn't be
mad if any of these teams win if it's
Kansas City if it's Kansas City uh 49ers
that'll be a great Super Bowl either way
it's going to be a great Super Bowl no
matter what Philly uh Philly Bengals
would be a great Super Bowl anyone needs
to be a great Super Bowl but I think the
49ers have enough
and I think Bengals are the best team I
think and I think they're going to win
the Super Bowl so
that's
that's where I feel that and I see
somebody in the chat chat can't sleep on
the Eagles defense I'm not sleeping on
them at all that Eagles defense they're
a number two defense I'm I'm with you
the Eagles defense is for real that's
why I'm I'm a little worried about the
49ers because of Brock Purdy is he gonna
be a rookie is his rookiness gonna show
up this is the game that's gonna show up
okay uh Eagles defense get after the
quarterback so but Shanahan's over I
think Shanahan's a better coach
so it's gonna be a great game regardless
I'm just telling you it's going to be a
great game I can't wait to see it I I
look forward to uh what's gonna be
happening with this so we'll see Eagles
are great 49ers are great Bengals are
great
Chiefs are great if Patrick homes is 100
but the Bengals have already shown we
got their number the Bengals think they
own the Chiefs they they just that's
what they think they're like we're
better than them so they got to beat us
uh we wasted this we're they're the
reigning AFC champions so until someone
takes them off they're the one right now
Bengals are the one I'm picking the
Bengals I think they're going to
uh the Super Bowl so all right y'all
that is
my sports weed cat the sports read cat
step up and get smacked all right
all right so that's uh what we're doing
with that y'all all right so there was a
couple of stories in the news I wanted
to like uh talk about
um this is weird man uh this was some
weird stuff dude did you guys see I
don't know if you guys saw this but
McDonald's accidentally gave a customer
five thousand dollars in cash
it went viral on hip on Tick Tock and he
returned it he returned it how did they
even give it to him you know like it's
like you know you had a McDonald's
and they give you five thousand dollars
okay accidentally yeah you know what I
mean and you both been like yo
um
for some reason y'all gave me a bag full
of money
um and so they ended up giving them like
200 in cash as a reward and like free
McDonald's for like a month or something
like that
you know what I mean so I was like oh
that's that's crazy
right
so what would you do that's my question
out to the chat would you give the five
thousand dollars back you know I mean I
mean I guess there's like
could it be like you could get away with
it scot-free but you feel like you you
get the money there's like cameras you
know what I mean there's cameras
everywhere you know so that they got you
and you know it's not your money so at
that point is it a crime like so like
let's say you could you know let's say
you know there's no cameras or nothing
like that and you get you get in your
car you drive away you look in the bag
and it's 5 000 in cash what are you
doing at that point
I don't know if I'm giving it back
you know what I mean I don't know I
don't know if I'm giving back five
thousand dollars I just like oh well
that's like the universe the universe is
like I need to pay some bills and they
sent me this five thousand dollars
through McDonald's I don't know
I don't know like what's the Good
Samaritan in this is that being a Good
Samaritan I don't even know if it is
like like why why is McDonald's got five
thousand dollars in a bag just sitting
on the counter like why is the five
thousand dollars you know in the
drive-through
you know what I mean like the person's
like oh you Big Mac okay here it is
thank you here you go thanks for coming
like who's not paying attention yeah
that seemed like that seemed like it
could be like a drug deal going on you
know what I mean like right don't you
think that they just
that just seemed like super weird man
that seemed like a super weird thing so
I don't know what you would do let me
know what you would do in the chat are
you giving back the five thousand
dollars at McDonald's accidentally gave
you you know I just kind of feel like
sorry sorry not sorry but at the same
time though and I don't know if
anybody's a cop out there or anybody
knows the laws so McDonald's gives you
five thousand dollars and they have a
camera looking inside your car and they
see that you know so they know they gave
you the five thousand dollars and you
don't give it back is that a crime did
you are you stealing now I think it is
because I remember hearing something
about a month or so ago about like a
bank
like a bank like accidentally deposited
two hundred thousand dollars something
like that it was like hundreds of
thousands of dollars into someone's
account and the dude was like oh wow and
he spent the money and then he got
charged because it was like hey that's
not your money so
I don't know I don't know it's it's it's
uh I don't know if so so if they were
able to track the guy down so it's like
what I'm saying is is he being a Good
Samaritan or is it just that somebody
found
you know he was just like oh well I got
to bring this back anyway because I know
who I am you know once again thanks for
that stupid chat for sir Ryan Vine
oh yeah thanks for the Super Chat that's
why you get 1.99 rap
okay so
um
I know you'd be like there was no money
in the bag I had a Big Mac in the back
I would quickly go to another McDonald's
this is what I would do I'd hit up
Rachel I'd be like Rachel go to
McDonald's right now and buy a Big Mac
large fries and a coke she'd be like you
shouldn't be eating that be like woman
would you just go get me the goddamn
McDonald's and then I would meet her and
and switch it out so then when they're
like hey I'll be like I didn't have you
know they'd be like you had to be like
oh no no here's you know here's me then
I would like I would be like go live
just for no reason go live at that time
you know what I mean just be like yo
y'all just left McDonald's you know what
I mean all I had in my bag was a Big Mac
and some fries oh oh McDonald's thank
you so much and then that's how I would
uh get away with my fight
get away with my five thousand dollars
I'll be like you can give me five
thousand dollars look I went live like
10 minutes later when I got home and I
uh you know
I was eating this how where did you
think I got this from you know what I
mean
yeah so
I guess we're all monsters right is that
is that basically what we're saying
right now that we're all freaking
monsters
all right so we talked about the uh
okay so we talked about McDonald's we
did the M Ms we did the the thing oh man
it's not even gonna be a long episode
today this video is I could do a little
q a too with the chat you know thank you
very much here's another story that I
you know it was it was it piqued my
interest for a second because I was like
oh man what but so I don't know if you
guys remember remember the Tiger King
man the Tiger King
um
the Tiger King Carol back remember Carol
Baskins from the Tiger King
so
she was claiming in Tiger King 2 which I
didn't see is that her husband remember
her remember they claimed that she
killed her husband you know they clean
her she killed her husband uh you know
they they're the dude the Tiger King guy
he was definitely talking about it and
he was like oh she she's a murderer she
fed her husband to the Tigers
um remember that and then so recently
she she and a new one she was saying
that oh I got a letter from the homeland
security whatever that I know my
husband's alive in Costa Rica or South
America or wherever you know that's what
I think Hitler meant you know
you like so I was thinking to myself
damn
but now they're debunking it though like
they're like they don't there is no
proof that because they're due to be 90
or something like that now uh you know
and why would he just disappear you know
what I mean it's just it's weird but the
thing is is like that's one of those
things where you got to take
documentaries with a grain of salt
that's where I'm at with documentaries
like every time I watch a documentary
I'm always like oh okay what is the
agenda here because they all got an
agenda there's no documentary that is
giving you like
here's the facts from both sides there's
always something that's being taken out
and it's skewed in a way to make you
feel hey this is
like this is how I feel about this
the only documentary that recently that
I've seen
um
the only document that I've seen is that
it was called don't answer the phone on
Netflix and I think I talked about it
already and one thing I liked about that
documentary is they were asserting that
that the cops believed that this one guy
was the caller calling the McDonald's
restaurants and convincing people to do
terrible things right they believed so
they were showing that cop's perspective
but what I like with the documentary did
was they went right over to the lawyer
of the guy and they let this lawyer give
his side and the lawyer was like there's
no way my client did this and they gave
that perspective and so this documentary
presented like two sets of facts and
then they let me decide what what I
thought of one the documentary as a
whole to these two sides and then I can
make my own assessment
something like the Tiger King
these people this is their agenda
they're like this guy's terrible this
chick's a murderer and she got called a
murderer for like five years now you
know what I mean and so
if this would have been true that her
husband was alive do you think those
filmmakers would have been like
oopsie sorry about that you know
here's why I'm I'm gonna tell you right
now why I'm off documentaries and I
don't mean to say that I don't like
documentaries I don't watch them what
I'm saying is I don't look at a
documentary and say to myself wow this
is a hundred percent true I'm gonna tell
you why
remember making a murderer
picking a murderer a 10-part Netflix
documentary and it took over the nation
y'all
it took over the nation
and I remember being outraged
I'm telling you I was so Furious that
that guy was in jail after seeing how
they laid out all of the facts and
information in that 10 part documentary
10-part documentary
when I finished that documentary I'm
telling you man I was having talks with
my friends I was like and then that one
organization that gets people out of
jail they got involved there was
petitions get him out of jail he
shouldn't be in jail
Well turns out
they left out a lot of information
turns out they left out all the
information that if you would have seen
it you would have been like oh he
probably did it
that's
what
they did
okay and so ever since then because I
just want to point something out to you
making a murderer was a fantastic
documentary that laid it out where you
thought the dude was innocent guess what
he's still in jail
serving that sentence because the things
that they left out like they have a
whole thing if you just Google uh like
you know
I'm just gonna do it right now facts
left out of make latest the first thing
that comes up is so hilarious
making a murderer key pieces of evidence
um
like they have oh it's crazy let's go
here on this thing right here you know
so they got like Avery strange purchases
uh hours of Desi confession I didn't
believe I didn't like that confession I
don't like how they got that confession
allegations of child molestation they
didn't talk about Daisy's failed
polygraph test they don't tell you about
um Avery called the girl three times
that day unidentified prince in the car
uh you know this is just this one
website previous animal cruelty the guy
had the matching bullet uh
their past interactions there were some
other ones about something about
something about they found his Sweat
There was like there's some other ones I
saw in another thing anyway my point is
ever since I saw making a murderer and
it made me feel the way I felt about it
and then to come to find out that the
the makers of this documentary left out
a lot of key information that would have
made you go oh well maybe he didn't do
it or maybe he did do it like they did
that they left nothing for you to
determine for yourself and that's to me
always a sign of a bad documentary just
a reminder that hey remember this is an
agenda that this person that is making
this has feelings thoughts and they're
trying to put that on you they're trying
to this is how I feel about it this is
what I want you to know and there are
other facts and information out here but
most people that watch a documentary
they're not gonna think like that
they're gonna think well this guy
obviously knows everything why why like
why would Netflix a billion dollar
company why would a billion dollar
company put something on their net on
their Network that doesn't have all of
the information like that's the thought
process you go down I'm telling you
right now it's all for entertainment and
everybody's got an agenda and ever since
then when I watch a documentary now I go
okay I don't know maybe you know what I
mean I just go maybe
so it's just it's just weird because
they're put together so well you know
what I mean like if you think about
making a murderer it was put together so
well you got well this has to be true it
has to be true that's the thought
process you go in because when you see
the word documentary you go it has to be
true turns out maybe it's not
you know what I mean the dude's still in
jail he's in jail he's in jail because
they had enough evidence to put him away
and they didn't show us all that in the
documentary so
it just made me think of that with this
Tiger King chick I'm just wondering if
they're gonna find her husband you know
he was he's been living in whatever with
his other family who knows and maybe she
did kill him maybe she did feed him to
the Lions you know what I mean because
she got like a lot of money out of that
I don't know man but it's just it's a
weird thought all right let's finish it
off with
I almost forgot like in the title uh
this is the whole point of
um this episode because I really enjoyed
this uh show so let's get into wait how
come it's not oh here we go
here we go wait what nope here it is
always Last of Us
I'm blocking the guy Pascal what a great
actor
so let's go over the last of us
um
what a great show man I I thought the
top no uh no spoilers I guess I and I
only played the video game just like a
little bit
I don't know if you guys really played
the video game you know a lot of people
um
you know they talk about the video game
it's like oh this is you know it's just
like the video game it's like I don't
really care about that I just want to
know is it a good story I like zombie
stuff this is sort of like a zombie
post-apocalyptic there's some sort of
disease that's like you know going
around that you know kill the population
that's just like a a very popular theme
it's a very popular themed
storyline
it you know it says after a global
pandemic destroys civilization a
hardened Survivor takes charge of a 14
year old girl who may be Humanity's Last
Hope
so there you go
if you know the video game you know that
the girls got there's a reason why she
could be the last hope and right now
it's just about you know going through
their story so the pilot I didn't like
the pilot as much as I liked the second
episode because a lot of times in a
pilot they gotta explain what's going on
this is what this is about these are the
characters this is the world this is
what's happening these are the good guys
the bad guys the the neutral people and
so you kind of gotta like gather all
this information about the world the
universe that they're creating and they
did like in they did an okay job you
know uh but like I say the dude Pedro
Pascal that I love this dude I believe
him anything he's in I believe him so
and the girl's doing a good job too
Bella Ramsey
um is that is that the girl that just
playing is it Balor Ramsay or is it just
other Gabriel Luna I think it's
both of those people were in it yeah no
no it's speller Ramsay so she's uh she's
doing a great job too this little girl
it's a great story they set it up you
get a lot of backstory you get a lot of
like okay this is what it's about and
then they're kind of showing you here's
the zombies here's the what they're
gonna look like and it's very they try
to stay true to the video game because I
saw a little thing about the making and
I was like oh that's cool they're trying
to like be true to the people who are
out there like oh yeah we we uh uh you
know we we know that that looks just
like the video game so and then they're
doing what they can
a lot of times with stuff like this I
feel like I wish the budget was bigger
you know it does look great like you the
clear CGI they didn't blow up a city to
make this so anytime you see that you're
like okay I believe this but sometimes I
feel a little iffy about like when they
go inside and this is clearly a set now
right oh this is a set
I just I don't know I don't know if they
did the best job of that stuff to make
me really feel like oh this is what was
going on because it's like 20 years
later and then like they're showing like
inside stores and there's still glasses
and cups on the tables and stuff 20
years later this place would be picked
dry there'd be nothing left nothing no
tables chairs anything worth of value
the people that have created this Colony
Community they would have came in and
got it there'd be nothing left so I have
a problem with that but it is
um
uh yeah oh oh that's right I see
somebody in the chat saying some of the
they did do they were trying to like
follow the the the game you know that
they had that game Exposition that they
do like when you're watching a good
video game and they show you they were
trying to follow that which I thought
was kind of cool so I think it's a great
show like I'm invested like I want to
watch till the end like I'm not I'm not
gonna check out on this show
um so that's uh you know I give it as of
right now it's gonna get like seven
woo-woos
foreign
I don't know if that was seven or not
but we did it
okay I'm gonna look in the chat for a
couple things somebody said did they
really cancel the Workaholics movie yes
they did Paramount plus canceled the
Workaholics movie oh you know what's
hilarious guys speaking of that
um
uh
uh wait the there was this um
there was this funny article man that I
saw
look at this it says workaholic star
Eric Griffin Shades Paramount plus and
Jamie Lynn Spears
because I I needed I tweeted out that
tweet right there I tweeted Paramount's
Global strategy starts here y'all and I
show a picture of of that you know
because I was like what you're gonna
make this movie but you're not gonna
make Workaholics so yeah I was throwing
some shade but it's just funny that they
uh they they wrote it like that
you know what I mean so it is what it is
um I see like these needy [__] in
chat right now are like hey my Super
Chat what about my Super Chat what about
stupid chat
you needy and whack
but Peter Gary
you probably Harry
Rock environment
the five dollars on it
thank y'all
uh yeah man I want to thank everybody
for listening to referring with Griffin
as always you guys are a pleasure to do
this for thank for the new people if
you're new thanks you like give me a
shout out to me if you like the show
maybe you don't like the show and you're
like hey I'd like to see this you know
let me know
um you know we're we're a work in
progress you know what I mean we're work
in progress here at riffing with Griffin
I know even though it's you know we're
at episode 217 I'm still at work in
progress you know but like I say make
sure you subscribe
um I got shows coming up I'm gonna be in
Escondido March 3rd and 4th I had to
cancel Jacksonville because I got
something going on on the fifth that I
have to be here for so I'm gonna be in
Escondido the third and fourth that's in
the San Diego area so come check me out
there uh I'm on Twitch I'll be on Twitch
in like 10 minutes so come check me out
there you want to be a patreon member or
a sub or you could be a YouTube member
any way you want to support the show in
that way I appreciate that uh you know
and I got you know and then I'm gonna be
at the Bell on February 10th I'm gonna
be at the Bell theater in New York so if
you're a New York area I'm gonna be
there one night so come check me out
there come and check me out I want to
see y'all there
okay so let's get to
um my favorite part of the show I just
don't know if this is wait let me see
how long is this
let me see how long this is okay this is
long enough perfect okay so my favorite
part of the show this is my boy Chris
you you know I always like to use his
Beats everybody you know what this is
you know what this is
it's the robbery cat
you know how we do
we do it with a wrap
oh Last of Us
it's like a bus
cause we taking a ride
like a sliding Glide
in the chat you could buy taking you
along for this ride
I strive
podcast alive
um
the NFL is gonna be the best better than
the rest
I always say it with my chest
here we go
sexy green
[Music]
you know what I mean
I've seen
and I did
all these [__]
on my streets
like a green machine Eric Griff is
getting laid oh blow it off Steve
[Music]
I like my [__] cream
here we go
she got to go
[Music]
Workaholics movie
you gotta be fresh all right y'all
thanks for watching we're from with
Griffin
thanks for watching thanks for being
here thanks for if you want to send a
beat send a bead to Eric and Eric
griffin.com I appreciate y'all once
again and we did it
as always
like I say thanks for being here you
guys are the best thanks for the super
chats thanks for the support thanks for
the comments and I will see you next
week
um
I don't even know if it's still on it
could be I don't know but I'm looking at
my screen waiting for it to turn off
that's how I do it that's why this part
is so weird all the time